bear how you doing brett
hey jesse uh we don't know exactly where
those biological research facilities are
on the map here but we do know that
russian forces are on the move and we've
seen them active in the kharkiv area
here some bombardments and outside
kiev a lot of the suburbs there is some
movement here and i want to talk about
that a little bit closer uh on this next
map and that is
this is jack keane's study group the
institute of war group and there are
seeing some significant movement of
russian troops uh from
the eastern part they're also seeing uh
down from the north and northwest in an
effort to encircle kiev they think
within the next 24 to 72 hours they are
getting resupplied by that base we've
talked about in belarus and that is
making that move a little bit faster and
whether they do that effectively is
really you know
yet to be seen in the south they've had
that success
that we talked about they are in control
of curson they've had bombardments in
maripole there's fighting in the south
they obviously have crimea the big
question is odessa right now there the
residents there are fighting back very
hard and they've got uh sandbags uh
there was a thought that there was going
to be a marine landing there
it has not happened yet for the russians
so we're watching that closely and the
other big story today is the migs and
what happens with poland's
invite they want to send their migs to
ramstein germany have the u.s somehow or
ukrainians get them to kiev but the u.s
is saying no we can't do that uh so
there's a big question about the migs
and what's going to happen to supply
ukraine obviously the ukrainians would
like to have that firepower we are fire
we are providing them stinger missiles
and javelins as well
but the polish put out the statement and
it caught u.s officials off guard today
and what happens with those mig jets is
really
a big question as of tonight
why do you think the polls would want to
transfer them to the u.s base in germany
first seems out of the way
why wouldn't they just have them
directly transferred to ukraine which
they border
right this is the question i think we're
seeing some geopolitical uh
face-off between allies that maybe there
was a blame game that poland was
dragging their feet on the mig-29s and
they said you know what we'll move them
to ramstein and then you tell us what to
do in other words forcing the body
administration's hand to say no um and
what's what's really going to happen is
both bases there are
are nato bases and
you know whether they come from germany
or they come from poland they're still
coming right from nato or the us so the
reaction from putin if you're concerned
about that or starting world war ii with
some elevation of weapons is the same
whether it comes from poland or comes
from germany uh so we're going to see i
think in the next 24 hours what happens
with those mig-29s yeah that is
interesting maybe i guess if the
americans touch the jets last yeah that
makes a difference
yeah exactly all right we're going to
follow that thank you so much brett you
bet all right